I told the mainstream media's anti-trump
echo-chamber they're at it again and
this time they're trying to take down
the president's pick to head the CIAA
her name is gina Haspel now hospital is
a career intelligence officer who has
been praised by colleagues for her very
important work after 9/11 and she would
be the first woman to serve as the CIA
director have confirmed the mainstream
media liberal Democrats they seem only
interested in smearing the long-serving
intelligence official Pro Publica was
recently forced to issue a correction on
a report accusing Hospital of overseeing
the waterboarding and abuse of a
detainee being held at a CIA black site
Abu Zubaydah the New York Times was
forced to issue a similar correction for
prior to those retractions identical
stories were echoed on multiple media
outlets including fake news CNN and
that's not all some of the media or even
denigrating hospitals achievement as a
woman Vox is calling her selection quote
not a feminist choice and the New York
Times published an op-ed titled Geena
hospitals rise is no victory for
feminism Wow here with reaction Fox News
national security strategist former
deputy assistant to the president
Sebastian Gorka and former White House
press secretary Sean Spicer yeah I can't
believe that you have to be a liberal
woman doctor Gorka is that is that what
it is you know in order to advance you
know women's rights you have to believe
in certain fundamental issues or this
does not advanced feminism and then I
heard Hillary this week say oh the
reason I lost is because white women
listen to their husbands to their bosses
and their sons before voting for Donald
Trump
let's just put to the side for a moment
Sean Hillary Clinton insulting 30
million American citizens who just
happened to be women and ask a very
simple question what has catching
terrorists undermining the enemies of
the United States and being a
professional intelligence officer got to
do with feminism we don't run the
intelligence
community based upon ideology that was
John Brennan that was under the Obama
administration we need to know one thing
about this woman and it's clear that she
has it is whether or not she's qualified
to be one of the most powerful
government officials in the most
powerful nation in the world the only
problem with this woman is sure it's
very simple she's a woman who's working
for Donald Trump that's the only problem
but it's actually worse than that Sean
this we lost 3,000 Americans on 9/11
2001 there was only three people
waterboarded but in the case of Khalid
Sheikh Mohammed it led to the courier
the courier led to bin Laden without
waterboarding KSM there is no bin Laden
what part of that do liberals disagree
with we're too tough on terrorists
that's why they don't want her well I
think dr. Gork is right on this it's if
she was working for Barack Obama they'd
call her eminently qualified in let's
look at who is calling her qualified
Leon Panetta hated Morell all of these
folks that have sort of at the top
echelon of the intelligence community in
a bipartisan degree one administration
over the next all support her because
she is eminently qualified with over 30
years experience but to your point Sean
here's the thing when if you don't fit
the category that liberals think you're
in depending on your race or your gender
then you don't count so Gina is not
qualified to be CIA director because
she's not a liberal you look at what
happened yesterday
the did the left-wing Democratic outfit
American Bridge assaulted assaulted and
was arrested a male staffer for them
attacking a female member of the Trump
administration and did you see any
coverage of it today no nothing in the
Washington Post nothing in the New York
Times there was a man arrested for
assaulting a female member and dr. Gork
is right why because she works for
Donald Trump if this had been the
administration over words it would have
been leading the evening news today the
hypocrisy and double standard is
unbelievable now I I just really look at
these times you have dr. Gorka this
cannot be emphasized enough the biggest
abuse of power scandal in the history of
the country
it's literally sitting right there on a
tee for the media the media all they
care about is stormy Daniels and Russia
Trump collusion and after what almost 18
months we have no evidence this is all
that they cover and it's amazing that
here with all the evidence we have
Hillary fixes a primary Hillary has
criminal activity that is fixed for her
she purchases lies and a phony Russian
dossier lie to the American people it's
used to obtain a FISA warrant and of
course they don't tell the FISA judge
that Hillary bought pay for it so we can
spy on an opposition party candidate and
campaign how about covering real news
for once well look that's not their job
these are propagandists and if you look
at the FISA gate scandal what we have is
Hillary Clinton the DNC affecting a
successful Russian operation because
that file was full of Russian
misinformation that's the enormity of
what we're talking about these people
aren't interested in the truth this is
perhaps the biggest scandal that we've
seen in a political election since 1776
and let's just remember one thing Sean
if she'd won we wouldn't know any of it
none of it not FISA gate not uranium one
it would all have been covered our up
and that's the scary thing all right
Sean Spicer I think you're missing good
I was gonna say I mean you look he got
more great economic news today if it
wasn't for the president tweeting it out
to his followers we wouldn't know about
it they're more worried about whether
one staffer could or should be fired by
the end of the week whether there could
be a mix-up I mean there's more time
spent confirming whether or not
somebody's actually in the office today
the the White House pool sent out a
report today that they cited at HR
McMaster the National Security Adviser
meantime the economy continues to hum
along and people are living better lives
in this country all right
unbelievable and I don't know how you
did your job I would have exploited it
spoiled it
I couldn't there was no and what Sarah
Huckabee does every day god bless you
both
you're better people than I am